it's happening hi my name is Afshin oh
yeah and I've never really tried trick
played I'm Ferren I have never tried
chick-fil-a before when I was younger
they would have these chicken options
that every time I had it was just like
this thin little patty I just never was
happy as a childhood I'm from San
Francisco and so we don't have a
chick-fil-a so it's just never been
something that I have even had access to
I've heard people saying chick-fil-a is
pretty good you should try it I was just
like if I'm gonna have a chicken
sandwich I'm gonna go to a more
established a very popular Nashville hot
chicken sandwich I've heard that
chick-fil-a has really great chicken
sandwiches I don't really know much
about I know there was like this spicy
chicken I believe and have a lot of
dipping sauces they are not very
supportive of the LGBT community and so
I feel a little bit bad today by having
it but also I'm not paying for it I'm
here now I'm excited to see what this is
all about let's see if it's actually as
good as people say it is I got friends I
have only heard about the chicken
sandwich at chick-fil-a so like I'm not
privy to like anything else on their
menu so we have four different sauces
garden herb ranch fancy fancier dancing
just ranch the later is like a chopped
tomato in there somewhere
the chick-fil-a sauce which I hear is
really really good I don't know what
your sauce means okay a Polynesian sauce
why okay cool and then we have a classic
barbecue sauce which is usually my go-to
like I get the nuggets of McDonald's I'm
usually going to barbecue I usually
don't mess with only these other sauces
but I'm excited to try them today so
I'll try to barbecue sauce I guess I'm
really good he's actually not bad waffle
fries they're not like the best fries
I've ever had but I can understand why
people would like these it's like very
thick it has a lot of texture to its
texture that makes sense there's a lot
of fry per square inch
I guess well maybe I like them with the
sauce let's try sauce let's do barbecue
okay she had a Polynesian sauce and what
that's about I was really good barbecue
sauce so I'm about this right now
I actually really like the Polynesian
sauce for an option to tip your fries
and it's actually really cool I'm not
usually a Dipper this
like saying a lot for me right now I've
never really had a sauce like that with
French fries which i think is really
unique these are really good like I
would highly recommend you chick-fil-a
waffle fries I have heard so much about
this freakin sandwich right now that I
am like super super excited to taste it
heard my friends talk about chick-fil-a
sandwiches I've never really been there
to physically see them have it but I'm
also really nervous because it's been
hyped up so much that like what if I
bite it and it's if it's trash you know
like what if I hate it worse off what if
I love it and then now I'm like addicted
to chick-fil-a even though I'm not
supposed to go there or I don't want to
go there and then I'm like this is the
best sandwich I've ever had what do I do
I'm gonna predict a bit okay unique
little bag let's see if it's all they
had it's hyped up to be interesting
oh it's kind of okay it's like super
basic it's just chicken and bread it's
actually a lot thicker than I thought it
would look like I think I'm used to flat
basic the moment of truth I'm like
really nervous right now this might
change my life here we go looks like
alright
this is actually a little better than I
thought overview I get the hype that's
really really good like it's moist the
bread is good like even the pickle is
nice like it's very well seasoned it's
not like oh my god like wow but it's
like okay this is faster chicken I like
the uneven texture of the Patty and how
there's like puffy parts thin parts it
feels like someone's grandma just made
it outside for you and pop it in it
feels a little more natural
alright I see you okay I'm gonna dip in
a Polynesian sauce let's try it with
this famous chick-fil-a sauce cuz I just
dip it in there like that Cheers
sauces make it a lot better I'm gonna
try to chick-fil-a sauce to see I don't
even know what your faucet is I'm not
mad at this at all like this is really
really good I would go back just for
this for sure 100% it's almost like
there's someone put Tripoli sauce mix so
Mayo or something I think that's why I
wish the chicken sandwich it's like this
great combo of like unique taste and
punch I think I need to finish this it's
so good
try to trip nuggets I actually didn't
know there was an option to get nuggets
we got nuggets you guys to dip or not to
dip okay that's a little clever I may be
real honest with you right now
McDonald's nuggets are like it for me
and like I don't usually like any other
places nuggets so I'm skeptical oh okay
this reminds me of the KFC called the
poppers but a lot fatter and less
breading which I actually really
appreciate actually like little chickens
in here I might have to eat those words
that I just said that McDonald's is up
here because these look really great
it's like a good piece of chicken these
are really really really good it's just
like real chicken I'm really obsessed
with a Polynesian sauce I feel like I
just want to buy a bottle of that just
take it home nope not for me not a fan
but different strokes for different
folks if I ever felt like having August
I would probably come to chick-fil-a to
try this these are good I would buy
these every time I go such a plate along
with the situation so I'm very happy
right now all right so now we're gonna
try their milkshake isn't always used to
the classic McDonald's vanilla chocolate
strawberry and cookies you Creed was
never an option that's why I was pretty
excited to try to cookies and cream when
I go to in and out I usually get you
know the number two with a strawberry
shake so I'm gonna see how chick-fil-a
measures up to in and out wow this is
actually really amazing that's good it
has a very nice heavy taste to it like
very rich that is so good but six are
actually really impressive I definitely
would recommend this milkshake if you
never had chick-fil-a milkshake I would
definitely go there gee I'm gonna finish
this for sure oh oh
overall my final thoughts of chick-fil-a
is actually a lot more impressive and I
gave it credit for I'm like not mad at
chick-fil-a at all because that chicken
sandwich was fire the chicken sandwiches
were a lot better than I thought it ever
would be this milkshake is delicious I
would definitely go back for literally
the milkshake alone the briber q sauce
is really really good
the Nuggets were good so far so hit like
I have not had one thing that I'm like
except for the Polynesian sauce sorry I
might actually start eating at
chick-fil-a and I just heard that
actually the one by our office is one of
the few chick-fil-a's that actually has
taken a stand against
they're anti-lgbt q-dance so I don't
feel as bad supporting that location so
I think if I do go to chick-fil-a again
that'll be the one that I go to I think
I'm gonna give trick play a little more
credit next time and go there 100% I'm
taking I'm gonna go there more often
with friends and just go check it out
like crazy so happy that's like I got to
try it for the first time
[Music]
you